Cada vez que un gobierno latinoamericano quiere
hablar de política exterior y desarrollo,
termina siempre hablando de integración regional.
Por eso no podemos extrañarnos de que Latinoamérica
tenga tres elementos característicos:
el fútbol, las revoluciones y los organismos
de integración regional.
En serio, no es broma:
En las últimas décadas han aparecido tantos
organismo regionales que es casi imposible
saber qué misión tiene cada uno, además,
claro está... de gastar dinero en sedes,
viajes y funcionarios.
UNASUR, MERCOSUR, ALBA, CARICOM, la Comunidad
de Estados Latinoamericanos - CELAC -, ALADI,
La Comunidad Andina, el SICA, el SELA, el
Grupo de Río, por supuesto también está
la Organización de Estados Americanos…
y, la verdad, seguro que nos dejamos unos
cuantos en el tintero.
Vamos, que a tenor de tantos organismos de
todos los tipos y colores bien podríamos
pensar que Latinoamérica es la zona del mundo
en que los países se llevan mejor, que es más
fácil hacer negocios entre ellos y donde sus gobiernos
trabajan codo con codo ¿verdad?
Pues… lo siento, pero nada de eso.
Una cosa son las intenciones y los anuncios
políticos y otra muy distinta la realidad.
Y es que amigos, todos estos organismos nacieron con
grandes objetivos pero prácticamente podemos
decir que todos se quedaron en nada si hablamos
de desarrollo o de integración económica
y política.
(“En América Latina se crean nuevas instituciones
pero no se aclara qué se va a hacer con las
previamente existentes. Es una permanente
huida hacia adelante y un constante añadido
de siglas y acrónimos a la voluminosa sopa
de letras existente”. Carlos Malamud)
Fijaos, a pesar de todos estos procesos de
integración el comercio entre los países
de la región es anormalmente pequeño.
(Los datos son contundentes, la parte de las
exportaciones que permanecen dentro de la
región se ha mantenido prácticamente invariable,
en un nivel de apenas el 20%, mucho más bajo
que el que encontramos en otras zonas del
mundo).
¿Qué mejor prueba de lo artificial y de
lo poco productivos que resultan todos estos
organismos?
Luego veremos en detalle el caso… bueno,
más bien la decepción o el fracaso de Mercosur.
Pero ya os adelanto que es muy posible que
en toda esta falta de integración real esté
el origen de algunos de los grandes problemas
de la región.
LA ETERNA PROMESA
América Latina, amigos, es una región fantástica.
Es tremendamente rica en recursos naturales,
cuenta con una biodiversidad y una variedad
climática impresionante y tiene un peso muy
importante en cualquier ranking que recoja
los lugares más bonitos de la tierra.
Sin embargo… económicamente las cosas no
pintan tan bien.
A pesar de todos estos formidables recursos
y su gran potencial, la región se ha quedado
atrás en términos de crecimiento económico.
Comparemos, por ejemplo, el caso del país
más rico a día de hoy de toda Latinoamérica,
Chile.
Pues bien, creo que decir que Chile lo ha
hecho relativamente bien en las últimas décadas
no le puede extrañar a nadie ¿Verdad?
Pues…a pesar de ello… atentos a este gráfico.
Ojo, hemos tomado el país más rico de Latinoamérica
y lo hemos comparado con Corea del Sur, que no
es el país más rico Asia Oriental. Pues
bien, el contraste es evidente.
En los años 60 Chile era un país pobre,
pero bastante más rico que Corea del Sur…
hoy las cosas, sin embargo, son muy distintas.
Podemos fijarnos también en Argentina que históricamente fue el país más rico
de Latinoamérica, con la excepción de Cuba.
Fijaos qué ocurre si comparamos su evolución
con la de España, por ejemplo.
Pues bien, es muy probable que una de las
causas de este menor empuje sea precisamente
la poca integración comercial y el exceso
de proteccionismo y burocracia que ha padecido
históricamente la región.
Es decir, mucho consejo, mucho acuerdo, mucho
foro, pero a la hora de la verdad, nada de
nada.
Pero, esperad un momento:
Hace unos años se puso en marcha un proyecto
de integración nuevo y completamente distinto
a todos los demás.
Y amigos, todo apunta a que no solo estamos
ante el primer proyecto de auténtico éxito
en la región, sino también ante una oportunidad
que puede cambiar el destino de toda Latinoamérica.
Hablamos, cómo no, de la Alianza del Pacífico.
LA ALIANZA DEL PACÍFICO
En abril de 2011, amigos de VisualPolitik,
Chile, Colombia, México y Perú, formaron
la llamada la Alianza del Pacífico.
Su misión: conseguir por fin una integración
que permita la libre circulación de mercancías,
capitales y por supuesto también personas.
Todo ello, con el objetivo de estimular, claro,
el crecimiento, el desarrollo y la competitividad
de sus economías.
"Nuestros países expresan el 55 % de las
exportaciones latinoamericanas […] Esta
no es una integración romántica, una integración
poética, es una integración realista ante
el mundo y hacia el mundo». Alan García.
Pues dicho y hecho.
Aunque aún queda mucho por hacer, desde entonces
el desarrollo del proyecto ha sido, como decirlo…
muy relevante.
En apenas 6 años estos cuatro países han
suprimido el 92% de los aranceles y han puesto
fecha para acabar con el resto.
Y, ojo, la integración comercial no se queda
ahí, también han simplificado y facilitado
los trámites aduaneros y burocráticos.
Especialmente los referentes a las reglas
de origen, que son un ancla enorme para la región
Fijaos, hasta ahora si un productor de Colombia
utilizaba proveedores peruanos, luego para
vender su producción a México no podía
beneficiarse del acuerdo de libre comercio
entre Colombia y México. Una locura.
Pues bien, ahora cualquier producto creado
en alguno de los cuatro países miembros es
un producto de la alianza y puede moverse
libremente.
Y ahí no acaba todo, para nada. También
se han eliminado los requisitos de visado,
lo que por ejemplo ha permitido duplicar el
flujo de visitantes entre estos cuatro países.
Y luego, muy importante,se ha avanzado bastante
en la integración financiera.
De hecho estos cuatro países han creado el
MILA, el Mercado Integrado Latinoamericano,
que ojo, es ya el mercado bursátil más grande
de toda Latinoamérica.
Lo que tarde o temprano facilitará que los
grandes capitales se fijen en estos mercados.
Y aún más.
Entre otras muchas iniciativas los países
de la alianza trabajan conjuntamente para
promocionarse en ferias internacionales;
han empezado a compartir embajadas en países
africanos y asiáticos
y han decidido negociar en bloque acuerdos
de libre mercado o acuerdos preferenciales,
lo han comenzado a hacer, por ejemplo, con
Nueva Zelanda, Australia, Canadá y Singapur.
“Australia y Nueva Zelanda comienzan conversaciones
comerciales con la Alianza del Pacífico”.
En otras palabras, estos cuatro países están
construyendo, poco a poco, un mercado integrado
que, ojo,… no será precisamente poca cosa.
Hablamos, amigos, de más de 214 millones
de consumidores y un PIB combinado que convierte
a esta alianza en una de las 8 economías
más grandes de todo el planeta.
La Alianza del Pacífico representa en Latinoamérica
el 50% de todas las exportaciones y más del
40% de toda la Inversión Extranjera.
Sí,  podemos decir que si la Alianza
del Pacífico continúa su buena marcha en
poco tiempo podremos considerarla la gran
fuerza, la gran potencia de toda Latinoamérica.
Pero para comprender un poco mejor todo los
logros cosechados en tan solo 6 años fijémonos
en el otro gran bloque de la región: MERCOSUR.
¿EL OCASO DE MERCOSUR?
MERCOSUR fue creado en 1991 por Brasil, Argentina,
Uruguay y Paraguay con la intención de crear
un gran mercado integrado entre estos cuatro
países.
Pues bien, qué decir, los objetivos eran
muy ambiciosos pero… los avances han sido
mucho más discretos. ¿Quereis una prueba?
Fijaos:
El comercio IntraMercosur representa hoy menos
del 13% del comercio total de sus países
integrantes. En 1995 era casi el 20%.
Es decir, que lejos de promover el comercio
entre sus miembros, casi podríamos decir
que MERCOSUR lo ha debilitado.
Y es que, en los últimos años MERCOSUR ha
pasado de ser un proceso de integración a
ser una especie de… como decirlo, escudo
proteccionista.
“Durante la última década, el comercio
entre los miembros del Mercosur ha crecido
más lentamente que entre los países de América
Latina que no pertenecen a él, e incluso
menos que entre los miembros del Mercosur
y otros países latinoamericanos”
Pero..¿Por qué no funciona? Pues fundamentalmente
porque no hay compromiso.
Teóricamente Mercosur es un proceso de integración
económica pero las salvedades y las excepciones
son tantas que al final, en la realidad, no
hay  nilibre tránsito de bienes ni de servicios
Al final,, MERCOSUR se ha convertido en un
organismo tan político como inoperante.
Fijaos, un buen ejemplo lo podemos encontrar
en la frontera entre Argentina y Uruguay.
En Teoría las fronteras internas no deberían
existir y las mercancías podrían moverse
libremente. Sin embargo, la realidad es muy
diferente y entre aduanas, inspecciones y
burocracia el paso de un camión de mercancías
por la frontera de Uruguay y Argentina puede
retrasarse más de 24 horas.
Todo esto, amigos, ha provocado que Uruguay
haya pedido formalmente convertirse en miembro
asociado de la Alianza del Pacífico.
Y no solo eso, el cambio político en Argentina
y en Brasil ha hecho que estos gobiernos acepten
que MERCOSUR tal y como hoy está planteado
no vale prácticamente para nada.
“Al mercado común nunca llegamos, la unión
aduanera está totalmente destrozada y la
zona de libre comercio tampoco funciona. El Mercosur está en un estado de inacción prácticamente total".
Por eso Macri ha decidido acercarse también
a la Alianza del Pacífico y buscar estrechar
lazos entre ambos procesos de integración.
¿Logrará la Alianza del Pacífico impulsar
el cambio en Mercosur? Desde luego sería
una gran noticia para toda la región.
LOS PUMAS DEL PACÍFICO
Pues bien, llegados a este punto nos queda
una pregunta ¿Por qué la Alianza del Pacífico,
a diferencia de todos los demás procesos,
sí parece estar funcionando?
Pues probablemente tenga que ver que los llamados
Pumas del pacífico - Chile, Perú, Colombia
y México que, por cierto, en los últimos
años han sido las economías más dinámicas
de Latinoamérica - compartan una visión:
Todos estos países parecen tener claro que
para crecer y desarrollarse hay que producir
y comerciar con el resto del mundo.
Por eso no es extraño que según el Banco
Mundial, estos pumas sean los países de la
región donde más fácil resulta hacer negocios
o que sean los países con más acuerdos comerciales
firmados con el resto del mundo.
En fin, la Alianza del Pacífico representa
una de las mejores oportunidades para que
Latinoamérica aspiré a convertirse en la
nueva región de moda.
Puede amigos que estemos ante el nacimiento
de una gran potencia económica.
Pero ahora, turno para ti ¿Crees que MERCOSUR
debe seguir los pasos de la Alianza del Pacífico?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo
dale a like y suscribete a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.